♪
>>> JAPAN'S ENVIRONMENTAL
MINISTRY SAYS TEMPERATURES ARE
RISING IN THAT COUNTRY AT A
FASTER RATE THAN THE GLOBAL
AVERAGE.
THAT MEANS MORE RAIN, MORE
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS.
IN TOKYO, THE WORLD'S BIGGEST
METROPOLIS, THEY'VE DEPLOYED A
UNIQUE WEAPON TO PROVIDE
PROTECTION FROM FLOODWATERS.
LUCY CRAFT TAKES US UNDERGROUND.
>> Reporter: TOKYO'S
OVERDEVELOPED LANDSCAPE CHRIS
CROSSED BY SCORES OF RIVERS IS
AT HIGH RISK FOR FLOODING.
A GOVERNMENT SIMULATION SHOWS
HOW PROLONGED TORRENTIAL RAINS
COULD LEAVE THIS METROPOLIS OF
37 MILLION UNDER WATER.
JAPAN HAS A NETWORK OF DEFENSES
TO SHIELD ITSELF FROM EXTREME
FLOODING EVENTS, BUT THE CROWN
JEWEL OF THE SYSTEM IS RIGHT
HERE.
70 FEET UNDERGROUND, A
SUBTERRANEAN SANCTUARY.
THIS IS A MASSIVE UNDERGROUND
FLOOD DIVERSION PROJECT, ONE OF
THE LARGEST IN THE WORLD.
IT'S BEEN CALLED A CIVIL
ENGINEERING MARVEL.
FACILITY CHIEF NOBUYUKI AKIYAMA
SAID THE FLOODWAY HAS PREVENTED
MAJOR FLOOD DAMAGE SINCE IT WAS
BUILT 15 YEARS AGO.
>> Translator: PREVIOUSLY
WHENEVER THERE WAS A TYPHOON
TOKYO WAS INUNDATED.
NOW EVEN WITH TORRENTIAL RAINS,
OUR WATER TANK HAS ROOM TO
SPARE.
>> Reporter: INSIDE A GIANT SILO
USED TO CAPTURE FLOODWATER,
SAFETY HARNESSES TETHERED TO THE
WALL ARE MANDATORY.
>> Translator: THIS SILO IS BIG
ENOUGH TO HOLD STATUE OF LIBERTY
OR EVEN THE SPACE SHUTTLE.
>> Reporter: THE SYSTEM IS
ACTIVATED UP TO EIGHT TIMES A
YEAR, DIVERTING FLOODWATER DOWN
SILOS INTO AN UNDERGROUND TUNNEL
AND INTO THIS MASSIVE HOLDING
TANK.
>> Translator: UNINTENTIONALLY
IT ENDED UP LOOKING LIKE THE
GREEK PARTHENON.
>> Reporter: IN DRY SEASON, THE
UNDERGROUND PARTHENON IS A
TOURIST MAGNET.
EACH PILLAR WEIGHS 500 TONS.
GAS TURBINES WITH THE HORSEPOWER
OF JET ENGINES PUSH THE
FLOODWATER OUT OF THESE GATES
AND INTO THE NEARBY RIVER.
NOW THESE GAS TURBINES ARE SO
POWERFUL THEY CAN CLEAR OUT AN
OLYMPIC-SIZED SWIMMING POOL IN A
FEW SECONDS.
THE FACILITY HAS CUT FLOOD
DAMAGE IN TOKYO BY 90%.
AS RAINSTORMS BECOME MORE
INTENSE, TOKYO WILL HAVE TO KEEP
UPPING ITS GAME.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING SATURDAY,"
LUCY CRAFT, SAITAMA, JAPAN.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> STAYING AHEAD OF MOTHER
NATURE.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> WOW.
>> IT'S JUST MASSIVE.
I'M STIL